speaking of I just thought of a tangent
oh yeah uh what about the etiquette and
taboos of pooping in different cultures
Howie what did you put into this AI to
get these problems uh I just I put in uh
give me talking points about a podcast
uh that talks about Japan anime pooping
and everything else and food here's the
pooping one so the Attica in Japan uh
you have to take your shoes off in some
places like you have to wear a different
pair of shoes oh yeah yeah like the
slippers you'll be in a restaurant where
you've taken off your shoes and go into
the toilet if you wear another pair of
slippers yeah a communal toilet slippers
yeah do you ever use the communal toilet
slippers
hell no
but it's kind of nasty when you think
about it it is like I'd rather just take
my risks and touch the floor because
yeah because like think about like the
amount of first of all like not clean
like socks and but potentially you know
just feed that appear yeah and it's
second of all in the case with guys
right like think of the amount of like
piss that just [__] flings out and
lands on the slippers right and I don't
know how often they're cleaning these
slippers so I assume not very often yeah
in some places right but but there have
been like it's it's a tire for me
normally I don't use it but there's
sometimes I walk in a toilet and I see
like a small little wet patch somewhere
and I'm like yeah sure I ain't taking
the chance man yeah I ain't taking the
chance yeah yeah that's the only time I
would wear if but if like the toilet
looks clean and there's like no
noticeable puddles or anything then I'm
just I'm just going in with my socks
yeah is there a culture in Japan because
I don't I don't know and I'm asking um
against like because in the UK and I
think the us as well there's kind of I
think it's a mainly the UK people really
don't want to [__] in public like they
[__] in a public toilet is like a is
that culture I don't know if it's
culture I think it's an individual thing
I know a lot of people who really will
do anything to not [__] I'm that person
you probably know a lot of people who
are like the same right yeah is it the
same in Australia as well or is it
um yes only because uh unlike Japan the
public toilets is disgusting they're a
bit more disgusting but I'm also a lot
more forgiving I hear [__] because I'm
kind of the mindset of okay I'm in the
mess okay there's there's I'm part of
the mess there's a lot of reasons why I
wanna [__] right in my the comfort of my
own I will never want to [__] in a
public toilet more than mine yeah of
course but let's let nature calls yeah
like let's take like let's say hygiene
out of it let's assume you live in Japan
yeah a country where the public toilets
are clean as [__] okay sometimes
sometimes sometimes I've seen some
gnarly toilets here yeah I don't know
like my Japan's track record for public
toilets compared to every other country
I've been to yeah it's really [__]
yeah I'll say that
um so taking that aspect out of it uh
there's one there's just you you know
sometimes there's just something
comforting about [__] in a place
that's your own home okay because okay
do you feel uncomfortable [__] in
your mate's place no ah yeah in fact I
try and do it every time I go to my
mates what the [__] okay what's wrong
that's the last time I invite you around
my house
I want to mark my territory
I think I got I I don't like it I think
you had this one time in your house I
don't know if you still do yeah you had
the first thing on your toilet oh yeah
that freaks me out oh yeah it's like the
last thing on the last thing I want to
picture is carpet and [__] like I want
it to be like porcelain so that if I
[__] everywhere it's super easy to wipe
all right but just a thought of rubbing
my ass cheeks against a carpet well I'm
gonna [__] I'm like oh oh yeah that's
that's a little strange
because in Japan they have you can get
the carpet on top of the toilet yeah I
have the carpet on top of the lid yeah
that's pretty normal but then some
people some monsters have the carpet on
the like actual part you sit on yeah
yeah and that's where I'm like it's a
bit weird
I think I'll just followed my wife on
that one
game I woke up one day and I'm just like
why would you do this what is this what
is this I had to I had to just get used
to it because like my grandma had it my
whole life yeah so I'm just kind of used
to it now but I not but in saying that I
don't like it I I like that we have
certain rules in society that we don't
change certain things and the design of
the toilet has gone unchanged for
generations and I don't think we should
start rethinking it I think the toilet
is a banger let's just stick with it
it's like this is why I hate it when
dudes wear like when it's in a formal
event and everyone's wearing a tuxedo
and a guy wears something other than a
tuxedo it's like okay what are you
trying to do here you're trying to [__]
with the norm everyone has a social
contract we know the tuxedo is the go-to
we all know that we can just whip out
the tuxedo and we're taken care of it's
fine don't start changing the norm don't
change the toilet okay here's a question
then if you're out in public right yeah
and and this applies mostly to people
who are comfortable with shitty in
public AKA Connor yeah right but say
you're in a situation and I'm sure
you've been in a situation like this
because I certainly have you'll you ha
you have to take a [__] like you can't
hold it in right yeah but that's fine
you're okay with public shooting in
public right you walk in and there are
only the Japanese style toilets do you
take a [__] if I gotta go I gotta go
I've never done it though I've never
chat in a Japanese style toilet which is
um as long as you just squat over a
whole yeah the squat toilets yeah I've
avoided it yes far have you have you
ever shown the Japanese style toilet
before oh I mean yeah I mean we have
those all the time in Thailand right
um it's better yes basically at every
gas station it's it's awful yeah
um
how do you avoid splashback
in what in the standing toilets because
you're dropping it like that that that's
gaining some G's that [__] like you
ain't dropping it that far mate wait
what are you standing up what are you
doing
come on no no the real question is at
what velocity does this [__] leave your
ass so much so that is splashing bro if
I'm dying and I'm using one of those
toilets it's probably a pretty vicious
Force that's coming out I would so how
low are we getting when we're shooting
are we like we're getting we're all like
like knees are like fully bent like this
knees are funny
in a Japanese yeah yeah no you're like
fully squatty yeah I thought it was like
a 90 degree kind of mean situation
are you just imagine does Connor seen
the squads only he's like all right
[Music]
I've never tried and I don't I don't
dare try it Conor just like takes his
trousers off and just stands on top of
the toilets
how do they get back up do people like
just get stuck no because they're
probably they have probably have to do
it every day no I've seen some old
people in Japan that can barely like
walk around oh they probably own Western
toilets in that case that's right there
too damn straight they do yeah that's I
think that's why every Asian is like
pre-programmed in their Gene to be able
to Asian school yeah just in case it
needs to [__] in a public toilet okay
here's another question when it comes to
Etiquette okay okay
um again this doesn't apply to you right
it applies to you though when you [__]
in a public toilet right Western one
okay do you use the bidet yes okay
because I know a lot of people who don't
okay so because it's like why would I
share a bidet with some random oh I'm
fine with sharing because like because
the way the bidet comes out right it
comes out like like this angle right and
the bidet shoots the water that way yeah
so there's no way it could get dirty and
even if it did it's like well it's no
more dirty than just putting your ass
cheeks on the toilet anyway that's
exactly and you're already washing it
with water so let's say even if there
was a tiny bit of dirt left on the bidet
somehow yeah it would get blown away
anyway from all the ass washing you're
doing right yeah I feel like that's like
a weird mind-blooding but I I know a few
people who have that mindset and I've
told them that exact same thing they're
like no it's still like if you're
willing to put your cheeks on the same
seat that like 1 000 plus other people
have put their cheeks on yeah and some
people are pretty good on the dirty as
well like I'm I feel like you have no
yeah like uh I think you'll find at that
point it's like whatever at that point
you use the Japanese
do you know one of like the scariest
sights to see in like a public toilet in
my mind like so so you need a [__] right
someone just goes out of the toilet
stall you go in and you see that they
put like the toilet lid down and you're
like oh [__] you have to touch it oh
he's he's just dropped a fat one because
you know what I mean because every time
that happened because you never like
when you go into a public toilet like do
you put the toilet seat down afterwards
no as in like after you take a [__] no
no uh no you I I only do that when I
know I've dropped a [__] stinker I
like a [__] nuclear bomb every time I
walk in a toilet store and I see the
toilet seat it's like fully down I'm
like someone's just [__] destroyed
this toilet and I don't know if I'm
emotionally prepared for me I'm more
scared of even though I just heard the
flush yeah I walk in and I see the lid
is closed somewhere deep in my mind I'm
like if I open this I'm gonna see that
guy's turn
he's left me a nasty [__] surprise
that I'm not ready to open this I'm not
ready to open this Pandora's box but I
need to it's the smell because I know as
soon as I open it it's just like I know
I'm gonna [__] smell it's gonna be a
bomb it's gonna be a bomb I know I'm
gonna hit me with hip with that wave of
smell and I'm like oh God why can't I
I've just waited like 10 more minutes
but a smell to dissipate but oh yeah
that's uh nasty do you use that weird
like toilet seat outline sheet you can
get at some toilets
um sometimes I do occasionally if it's a
really nasty looking toilet I'll try but
I guess so frustrating because it never
stays on the [__] seat yeah yeah you
know what I'm talking about yeah you can
get these like kind of toilet paper
style things that kind of go around the
whole toilet and then you poke out it's
like a serviette this is really weird
and it's so fidgety and it never stays
in place and I have to like quickly put
it down and get my ass on it stays yeah
I hate that thing so much because it's
so thin so the lightest Breeze just
[__] yeah
and your the pressure from your ass
approaching will blow it away yeah yeah
yeah
um and so I I normally don't use it but
yeah but sometimes yeah sometimes a
little extra protection doesn't hurt
yeah you probably love the they have
this thing as well it's pretty common
um where you can clean the toilet seat
if you want to oh with the wet wipes
there's like a there's like a another
spray it's not for your hands
um it's like for you can put some of the
toilet roll and then wipe it yeah yeah
let's do that occasionally yeah it
depends how spicy I'm feeling if it's a
long one I'm like I'm just getting
settled in let's do it okay here's the
question here's the question what do you
do you're desperate for the toilet go in
a public toilet you walk in no toilet
paper and you realize too late
uh uh I've never had that issue you've
never had that issue
or like it's either like there's no
toilet paper or of course I have oh it's
that's what this is why I hate going
into public toilets uh well that's why I
always check before I go in sometimes
you just forget because you're just too
[__] desperate then you that that
first one comes out it's a fat one you
look over you're like oh no Defcon five
it's it's an emergency meeting time guys
hopefully you're with a friend and they
can get help that's like the play right
yeah I mean not your [__] or see
because I've learned from that and so
now in whatever bag I have while I'm out
I always have like pocket tissues just
in case because you never know I think I
have had this I think everybody just
like had a really dirty ass and walked
to the next toilet
because I had no other choice like what
can you do yeah I mean like what like if
you're alone what can you do it's like
it's like when you're at home as well
though right and you realize that
there's no toilets like toilet paper on
the toilet roll you look to where you
usually have all your toilet paper
there's none there either yeah right so
what do you do in that situation at home
uh it's go in the shower yeah yeah I
just I just like shower shower that [__]
away shower strap yeah just the good old
the good old [__] shower strap